[Music]
we're nearing the end of this crazy
almost dystopian year 2020
so for fans of speculative fiction and
in particular
those interested in my series worlds of
speculative fiction
it's now a long established tradition
that i
start looking for suggestions for
who to put in the final three slots for
2021 so what i'm doing here in this
video is giving everybody
a chance to provide their initial
suggestions
and comments one author per comment
please
don't throw in everybody but the kitchen
sink just pick one
author for your person that you want in
there and then i'll take the top six
and we'll do a vote later on this month
of december and pick the
top three make your comment after you've
heard the rest of this video because i'm
going to tell you
who were already lined up for doing in
2021 you don't want to
ask for somebody who we've already
incorporated before i do that though let
me say this so
those who are watching this video what's
this all about
i have been doing this talk series a
monthly talk series
most months at least called the worlds
of speculative fiction
since we moved back here to milwaukee
and i started it in january
of 2016 and we found ways to continue it
during
covid so it's been going on
we'll be going into the sixth year of
the series yeah year number six
so we've covered a lot of different
authors
i'm going to be picking out some some
new ones and some old ones for
the year to come and each of them
focuses on you know a little bit of
biography
and a little bit of backstory a lot on
the narrative worlds that have been
created within
series of short stories or novels or
novellas
by this particular author and then
philosophical
themes and you can see if you click show
more
the entire playlist i'll link to that
you can check out all of those
videos if you want to we have some
really great discussions
over the course of the years originally
it was a
in-person face-to-face thing that i
would record at the brookfield public
library
obviously with covid19 from march of
2020 onward
we haven't been able to hold these
sessions and then i realized i could
keep on doing these by
recording them here in our apartment
and you know doing a video premiere for
about an hour and a half
talking about the particular author and
text and then we would do
a video conferencing session that's a
little bit more intimate
and a little bit more directly engaging
for people who are really into that
particular author
so we're going to continue on with this
for 2021
and we're going to start out online and
then eventually we might be able to move
to face to face we'll see what
actually ends up happening i i don't
know how this is going to work out you
know maybe with a vaccine we'll be able
to start
meeting at the library sometime during
the year or we might just stay
online for the entire time so that is
the series let me tell you who we've
already got
lined up so in january we are going to
be doing
somebody that has been requested quite a
few times and i had scheduled before
uh liu tsi shin the remembrance of
earth's past
trilogy which is is quite good in
february we're going to be returning to
philip k
dick and we're going to be looking at
novels
and also some short stories that have to
do with colonization
of the solar system and with themes of
insanity and sanity there's a lot to
play out in there so obviously like you
know three stigmata of palmer
eldritch we might put in maze of death
even though that's outside of the solar
system
but but some of the other ones as well
like martian time slip
then in march we're going to be reading
some big thick books
our scott backers prince of nothing
trilogy we're not going to try to
attempt to do the entire seven
volumes so far of the second apocalypse
series that the prince of nothing
trilogy is the first three books in each
of them is
is pretty dense and backer is a very
philosophical author
so we're going to be going through those
in
april we're going to pick up uh margaret
atwood's gilead dystopia
so her recent novel um the you know
handmaid's tale and and maybe a few
things
in between in may we're going to be
returning to philip jose
farmer who we did with the river world
series in the past
and we're going to be looking at the
world of tears
novels which are actually earlier than
the river world ones
very interesting stuff we might get in
the seventh
one which i'm not going to tell you too
much about here but it's it's kind of a
meta novel in some ways in june
we're going to return to somebody that
we started out talking about in the very
first year of the series
actually in the very first few months of
the series a van vock one of my
favorite authors from my my childhood
and we're going to be looking at his
weapon maker series
of novels maybe smuggling in a few other
things as well
in july we're going to be returning
again to octavia butler
we did our xenogenesis stuff in in the
past we're going to be looking at the
parable
series now in august
fan requested jg ballard we're going to
be looking at some of his modern
dystopias
and seeing if we can put together a
coherent narrative world maybe yes
maybe no we'll see what happens and then
finally in september
neil stephenson's anathem uh novel this
the
the single big thick um you know
really long enough to wrap our heads
around philosophical
novel by by that author so you notice
what we haven't talked about there
october november december that's up to
you
you are going to be providing
suggestions
in comments and then i'll take the ones
that have the most
um you know repeated calls for those as
comments on this video
and i will um
come up with the top six then we'll have
a vote towards the end of this month
and that will determine who will be
adding
in october november december and we
might actually be meeting face-to-face
by then who knows uh
you know we can we can hope for things
so uh pick
your favorite uh author who i haven't
covered
uh and you might want to take a look at
the series who we've already gone
through and what what particular
narrative world so you're not repeating
yourself so pick an author that you'd
like
me to take on write it in a comment
remember one one author per comment
and if you can say what narrative uh
series or world you want me to focus on
right because some authors have a number
of different
narrative worlds so you know try to be
as specific as possible
this will be a lot of fun i always like
to see what sort of feedback
i get from followers and fans and people
interested in speculative fiction i will
say this is
to sort of close us i have really
benefited
from the suggestion of some of the uh
people
who came to the original talks and would
would you know suggest people to me
year after year after year and from
people
on the internet who watch the various
talks and and
during these voting sessions were like
hey i want you to do this i want you to
do this
there's a lot of thinkers like for
example r scott backer
hadn't read him came up year after year
after year
got around to reading him was blown away
by how how cool the stuff that he was
doing was
all sorts of examples like like that so
make your suggestions
and if there's enough other people
sharing your suggestions you're going to
see that person
go up into the top six and then we'll
vote for
the top three after that
[Music]
you